[Music]
randall
yes you have been married for how long
four oh gosh
uh over 10 years oh gosh
oh gosh i feel like every guy
when they're asked i'm put on the spot
like how long you guys been together
oh [ __ ] i should know this or if my wife
is gonna get mad
well i needed that oh gosh to calculate
i need a good time it's a buy time
my girls are like bam 22 years in three
months
five minutes over 10 years is kind of
imprecise
like it could be like 13 years well i i
i mean 10 years okay 10 years okay okay
a decade wow so you guys like just this
last year you celebrated a whole yeah
that's a milestone do you celebrate
every year like a wedding anniversary
uh yeah we celebrate every year but you
know it the
celebrations become less elaborate over
you know it's like dinner
hanging out was it a bigger celebration
for the 10 year mark
huge party last this past year
it was just a high five you know what i
mean
we did it
so how long did you guys date before
getting married uh not that long we
dated uh
we dated for a year
a year wow and then and then we got
engaged and then we
married six months later wow were you
guys already older like in your late 20s
or early 30s or like
yeah or yeah early to mid 30s early
early 30s early 30s yeah
yeah early 30s so and we knew you know
if you're
if you do like a kissing scene on set
after you're done do you like
immediately look at her see how she
views you no
i make sure she's not there it wouldn't
make the scene uncomfortable
you can't like i like that he won't let
the actress's face go
it's okay
[Laughter]
yeah that would be really weird yeah so
i guess you don't do that okay
okay plenty all right well
the reason why i ask is because there's
this tweet that went viral recently
and the it's a thread and so it begins
with
don't get married before a thread okay
and it's
i can't guess what is it don't get
married before um
you talk about if you have stds or not
that's part of it
really good guess that's a really good
guess it's a good starting point yeah
that's good
actually 20 20. 20 things on this list
that this girl
like she's saying like you know every
couple should have discussions about
these
20 things oh they're only discussions
they're not experiences
because one of mine would be like if i
were to tell taika don't get married
before you guys have moved in together
oh yeah i would say you guys move in
first
we live together live together for a
couple months or a year or something
and then tiger throws his toy on the
ground
and his chicken goes no no no no no no
no
i'm cute okay no yeah they're mainly
discussion so number one
talk about debt is what she writes ooh
talk about oh yeah yeah that that is a
good one
when you get married they could lower
your credit score yeah that's right
i was actually really nervous to find
out his credit score because
but did you find out that says it all
found out after you got married or did
you find out like while you were
did you do it before you got married
have the discussion before it was after
oh yeah
that's why i was like i was like luckily
look he had a higher score than me
yes i was like what were you worried
about
baby i'm sorry but you cannot take this
credit it was all your mom
i know i know for sure no because like
there were so many instances throughout
the time that we were dating
that he like he'd get a phone call from
his mom and be like
you know you haven't paid this credit
card bill and it's like about to be
overdue and it's gonna damage your
credit all these things
and but i didn't know that they were
like
you know helping you take care of your
credit i just knew that he just had
overdue bills
yeah so i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm really
nervous so
so okay before you got married let's say
if you had the discussion
right in case you said my my credit
score is
or my 400 or something or it's just like
is that a make or break
would you have not married him oh that's
a good question
what if he was like it's 400 but don't
worry my mama's got it
oh no that's really bad
that's pretty bad i think it's it's a
discussion yeah because like hey i got a
score of 400. but wait mom's got it
undercover
it's like oh cool that's that's tight
all right yeah she's got it under
control yeah
honestly i don't know because there's a
lot of factors so i think i would have
been like well how about we hold off on
the
legalities of getting married we fixed
it
into the security blanket that is my mom
you
married into a well i just like that tim
is standing in front of a dumpster fire
that is her credit score and she's like
well
at least i made this hold
on it's all me that's all me back there
baby
i'm like at that time i was high seven
seven hundred
that's right hi hi seven hundred anyway
damn
all right so number two on this list is
fully and willingly committing to one
another
no i'm not sure and what ifs and
it's not the right time either you are
in or you are
out is it one of those things where it's
like i still want to [ __ ] around but i
want to be with you
i guess like is that kind of commitment
that's not being committed
i mean like is that the type of one foot
in one foot out that they're talking oh
yeah yes yes yes
yeah yeah or like you know so it's just
it's just saying you got to be in
all in yeah yeah no questions are given
why the [ __ ] to get why would you get
married
then just stay together some people kind
of like just ouija board their life
though
they're like you want to do it i'll do
it okay are you sure i don't know and
then they just
show up at the altar and then they're
like all right there's a joke
there's a very different specific you
almost got married as a last-ditch
attempt
i was in the last attempt what was it
what happened no we're not gonna go
there i wanna go there
well here's the thing is that um i've
always expressed
that i loved her this is my ex and she
did not believe it
and then um it was and she was saying
basically you need to commit
in a way where i feel secure and i'm
like okay
like i'm maybe we won't have this
elaborate like
proposal and all that because we're not
in a great place
but i do see a future with you so let's
just
go ahead and get legally married and
then we'll hash out all the things later
i'm not in a desperate last ditch
attempt to save it right true true so
like
i think that um in that case
it wasn't uh one foot and one foot up it
was like commitment showing going
forward that
we might have problems but i'm here to
look at the future
and how i have hope that we can work it
out so then that's beautiful man but
then
yeah you but the [ __ ]
that you put it sounds like i'm
desperate to save this
but it's more like i'll go through the
burden in in good faith
of like trying to fix it it's a funnier
comedy movie it is a funnier movie
to say that way but she tells the story
from the other side of the fence a
little bit a little bit
a little bit and maybe i helped maybe i
think that's why we didn't work out is
because we couldn't see eye to eye
of how to resolve it right but we're the
problem to
so so in your head the problems didn't
seem insurmountable like you
i thought everything could be fixed yeah
but then now
i actually believe that um
she might have she she was right in the
sense where
splitting up was the better move i'm
much [ __ ] happier
like being alone yeah so i think that
that took the separation for me to
understand that
this is a way better life for me right
right but you were just
but in the moment i think that's just
how my brain works is i need to
win so even if it's something that's
crumbling and it's kind of like
there's no hope i have hope yeah so if
you tell me
there's a one percent chance of winning
i'm grabbing that one percent and i'm
saying we're gonna win yeah yeah yeah
but you can't get married off a one
percent chance
[Laughter]
you know what i mean one percent chance
turns into a hundred percent if you
if you can fall into one percent right
right right yeah right that's my
mentality
right right but see that answers that
question because we were asking like
who would get married on something like
that and i think that that that
beautifully answered it yeah
yeah okay moving on in that case though
it sounded more
irresponsible where it was kind of like
well i don't really know my future but
like
let me just let's just [ __ ] do it
well there's a lot of ways that i'm
interpreting that too
because it could be someone that is like
well i really love you and i really love
what we have
i just haven't really fulfilled this one
part of me like i really want to do that
it could be that situation too who knows
like i haven't had a threesome yet so
marriage is a funny thing because
there's also people where i see them
a thousand percent committed at this
very present moment
right and then you're like they're to
last forever and then literally like two
or three years in
they're divorced stop stop tweeting no
no you see that right and then you also
see like
a couple that are like i [ __ ] hated
it's guts from the start
and we're 50 years in i still hate his
[ __ ] cuts right
but you guys are still married it's just
such a crazy well they i mean they they
isn't there a lot i i i think i read
that there's like statistics on arranged
marriages which are like
and they're actually like pretty success
yeah they're like zero percent committed
in the beginning
yeah yeah but now they love each other
like crazy but i also think that
when the roles are already set forth by
you and you don't have to think
about things every single time because
the the i think the burden of today
is the the too much freedom there's
it comes with a combination of like
having to know yourself first and
foremost and love yourself first and
foremost right so like
if you're not self-aware of those things
then
you can easily get into the relationship
with so much past baggage and you're
blaming the other person for everything
right and then you you kind of like
think that they're the problem and you
keep going into
relationships thinking like man all the
women in my life suck
right it's you yeah right but if you're
just in the range of marriage then you
kind of go default into
well a man's supposed to be doing this
so
okay i gotta do my duties and just to be
perfectly clear we're advocating for
arranged marriages yep yes
big time big time because my grandma's
worked out with a divorce
well i thought you said your grandma's
worked out if they're a lesbian i was
like wait what
[Laughter]
a strange arranged marriage
yeah well there's a ton of other things
listed here and a lot of them are really
good i'll go
through them quickly so you guys can get
an idea so number three is when
slash how many kids y'all want to have
adoption
one of you infertile et cetera number
four talking about stds get checks seek
medical ah i told you [ __ ]
yeah all those things keep those tests
up to date and find ways to do
so even within the marriage number five
talk about your five to ten year
timeline regarding career education can
you move willingness
to relocate level number six levels of
religiosity and like openness to growth
or lack thereof number seven anger
management issues do one of you struggle
are you in therapy for it slash taking
it out on others seek help because it
will destroy or destruct you
and the future and the children create
energy does it match
you decide follow your gut number nine
clothing it may seem like a small
problem but small things eventually add
up clothing make sure you're at this
point don't even be with anybody like
okay like fashion sense this person's
doing a listicle they get paid for doing
a certain amount and they're like i
don't know clothing clothing
because the first ten were like funny
yeah that's actually the reason why this
thread went viral because
like i said there's there's 20 right so
there's way more and they get very
specific
very detailed yeah not just that but the
reason
as to why it went viral because a lot of
people are saying like you're never
gonna get married then if you're going
through like if
everything in this list is it needs to
match you
to the t you're not gonna find that
person well if you're trying to
have these conversations at a strip club
they're hard
yeah because these are deep
conversations you need to have like
music's too loud
heart to heart times but i do think
these are important conversations to
have
you know even the other ones like i
think they are important conversations
to have like for example like opposite
gender boundaries like set what's okay
what's not okay like hugs handshakes
because other people have different
boundaries
yeah or social media like believe it or
not she says believe it or not people
will break over
break up over this some prefer privacy
some don't i'm still
like clothing like what what
i don't understand it i still don't
understand these authors are great
but i don't get close guess what it went
viral because it was so kick ass okay
when i read that one i actually thought
about david
and mariel like do you know david so
yeah so
david says like how when they were
dating like his the way he dressed
was kind of an issue a bit with them
like because they he'd be wearing
flip-flops to like a wedding or
something like and she's like
come on i look nice this is our wedding
what are you doing yeah
yeah well they are engaged right but
yeah so
i i understand how that can be an issue
in a relationship so
i don't know there's other things so if
you guys are interested you can click
the link in the description check out
the rest of the list
well people change too so you never
believe their damn answers
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can run around yeah you can get
a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you